I have the funniest thing to show you.
Donald Trump is of course panicking about
his former national security advisor, John
Bolton, possibly testifying in the Senate
impeachment trial.
Now, why is Donald Trump panicking?
John Bolton says in his upcoming book and
would likely say under oath that he knows
Trump was with, was withholding aid from Ukraine
until they smear Joe Biden.
Because Trump personally told him that this
is the assertion that John Bolton has made.
So yesterday Donald Trump retweeted a video
of John Bolton being interviewed by radio
free Europe back in August with the text game
over in all capital letters, letters.
So clearly Donald Trump believes that what
Bolton says in this video proves either that
Bolton is lying about what Trump told him
regarding withholding aid to Ukraine or that
what Bolton says proves Trump really did care
about corruption in Ukraine and not smearing
Joe Biden or whatever the case may be.
So I was interested and I watched the clip,
which is only 40 seconds long and what Bolton
says is definitely not exculpatory of Donald
Trump.
And it actually could be self incriminating
if we pay close attention to what it is that
John Bolton says.
So let's first take a look at the clip, then
I'll explain to you what is going on here.
We'll be meeting presence Lansky.
Uh, he and president Trump have already spoken
twice.
A president called to congratulate presence
Lansky on his election.
And then on his success in the parliamentary
election, they were very warm and cordial
calls.
We're hoping that there'll be able to meet
in Warsaw and have a few minutes together,
uh, because the success of Ukraine, uh, maintaining
its freedom, uh, its system of representative
government, a free market economy, free of
corruption, uh, and dealing with the problems
of the Donbass and the Crimea are high priorities
here obviously, but high priorities
for the United States as well.
So what's the big deal?
Well, John Bolton says in this clip, the success
of Ukraine maintaining its free market economy,
free of corruption is a high priority in the
United States.
You don't usually say we want to maintain
something unless it already exists.
John Bolton says in this clip that the Trump
administration wants to maintain and Ukraine
corruption free.
Now Donald Trump and his lawyers have been
arguing endlessly that Donald Trump did all
of this crazy stuff because Ukraine is so
corrupt and the corruption has to be fixed
and Trump feels so strongly about it that
he said, let's pause the aide.
That's the word they've now been using.
And yet John Bolton said back in August, we
want to maintain Ukraine's free market corruption
free economy.
This makes it more likely that fixing Ukrainian
corruption was never really the issue because
John Bolton said in August they are corruption
free and a free market economy.
So this is a new data point and this new data
point suggests that at least John Bolton didn't
see Ukraine as a corruption riddled mess since
he says we want to keep Ukraine free of corruption,
now you can parse the language some other
way.
You could rewrite the interpretation.
You could say, well it used to be not corrupt.
And then at the time of this interview Ukraine
went back to being corrupt.
And what Bolton meant is they want to go in
and rid Ukraine of corruption.
That's fine.
Right?
And we th there is no question that to some
degree Ukraine does deal with corruption.
That's not what's at issue here.
But the plain and simple outcomes raiser interpretation
is that Bolton is saying in the clip, which
is about six months old, Ukraine is relatively
corruption free and we want to keep it that
way.
This hurts the credibility of Donald Trump's
story because we are told that Trump was so
acutely concerned with corruption and Ukraine,
which was the acutely corrupt place that he
went out of his way and personally got involved
in saying, let's withhold the aid temporarily.
Let's pause it as they say, until corruption
is rooted out in Ukraine, it's just not believable.
When you see John Bolton say, yeah, we want
to keep you crane corruption free.
Number two, there's a reason Donald Trump
tweeted this.
Donald Trump tweeted this video because he
thinks it makes him look good.
Trump is tweeting John Bolton's own words
as reliable evidence.
In other words, Trump tweets this video because
he believes that the content of what John
Bolton is saying is exculpatory.
We've already showed that the content of what
Bolton says is not exculpatory, but the fact
that Trump is saying, watch this video to
figure out why I'm not guilty means he thinks
Bolton can be believed.
In other words, if he believed Bolton was
a liar, he wouldn't tweet a clip saying, look
at what Bolton says is evidence that I didn't
do anything wrong.
So Trump wants you to believe that he's innocent
because you can trust what Bolton says in
the clip I just played for you.
But he also wants you to believe that if Bolton
were to testify in the impeachment trial and
show up and say from told me to withhold the
aide until Ukraine smears Biden, in that case,
you would not be able to believe John Bolton
in this case, John Bolton's words are so trustworthy
that as far as Donald Trump sees it, they
are exculpatory.
It's a mess.
It is an incoherent, laughable mess.
And in the end, it's probably not going to
matter.
I wish I had some other conclusion that was
less disgusting, but in the end it probably
won't matter because I continue to believe
acquittal is a foregone conclusion.
And I know every time I say this, someone
writes to me, sometimes people will say, David,
you're being defeatist.
No, I'm being realistic.
Someone will write to me and they'll say,
David, by predicting the acquittal of Trump,
you were normalizing disgusting partisanship
on the Baja, on the behalf of Republicans.
No, I'm not normalizing it.
I'm telling you, it's so bad that there's
not even really a trial going on here.
It's just a farce.
It's a kangaroo court.
They may not even have witnesses, if you can
imagine that.
So I am a realist on this program.
I don't know what the audience gains from
me saying, Hey guys, I really think there's
a shot.
If we call our senators, I don't.
That's my belief.
And if I end up being proven wrong, I will
come back here and say, I got it wrong, but
I'm not going to Gaslight the audience.
And if the real, if the reality of what I
tell you, um, makes you feel bad or makes
you feel like we're conceding, I am informing
you to the best of my ability.
I don't see any path to conviction for Donald
Trump and the Senate impeachment trial.
And so I'm not going to pretend otherwise.
I see a possible path to getting witnesses.
If a few Republicans say, let's get witnesses
here.
I see a path to that.
I see no path to Donald Trump's conviction.
I see one path that his removal and it's an
overwhelming turnout against Trump in the
November election coming up in just nine months.
Follow the David Pakman show on Instagram
for more on this and other stories from today
at David Pakman show and follow me on Instagram.
Why not right
at David dot.
Pacman.
We'll take a quick break, so much more to
discuss